قال محمد ابو مصبح مدير الاسعاف والطوارئ
والمتحدث باسم الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني في
قطاع غزه قال انه تم فتح ممر انساني
للنازحين في مستشفى الامل تحت تهديد
السلاح واقتحام دبابات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي واوضح ان جيش الاحتلال اطلق
النار على المباني التي تؤوي نازحين وهدد
بالقتل كل من يريد ان يبقى داخل
المستشفى ما زلنا متواجدين في مستشفى
الامل اليوم قمنا ب فتح ممر انساني لعدد
النازحين المتواجدين في المستشفى تحت
تهديد السلاح واقتحام الدبابات بشكل مباشر
الى المستشفى والتهديد بالقتل لكل من هو
مستمر في البقاء في هذا المكان
اي تم اطلاق العيارات الناريه الثقيله
باتجاه المباني اللي بتواجد فيها النازحين
النازحين تركوا امتعتهم ومعداتهم وادويته
وحتى ذوي الاعاقه منهم حمل على الاكتاف في
طريق جدا وعره وصعبه وتحت تهديد السلاح
لمسافه تزيد عن 5 كو مت ومروا من خلال
حواجز تم فحصهم وتفتيشهم بشكل كامل بتفتيش
جسدي وتم اعتقال جزء منهم ومن بين
المعتقلين احد زملائنا في ضباط الاسعاف
اود التاكيد بانه بعض العائلات هي ماتت
بلا ماوى للمره الثالثه على التوالي وهي
تتواجد الان على الطريق الساحلي لمحافظه
خان يونس هذه اخر التحديثات بالنسبه
للهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني نؤكد بانه اليوم
هو اليوم ال عش على التوالي لحصار مستشفى
الامل
وفشلت جميع
تنسيقات ادخال الاكسجين والمعدات الطبيه
الخاصه بالجرحى وبعض الادويه الخاصه
بالمرضى بالمقابل تم منع ادخال الوقود
والمواد اللوجستيه الى الطواقم العامله في
المستشفى لتزيد من صعوبه تعزيز وود
الطواقم في مستشفى
الابل